初めまして僕は微生物の研究をしている慶應義塾大学環境情報学部4年の伊藤康平と
言います本日は僕はとても大好きな微生物についてお話したいと思います早速ですが
右側にある写真こちらは微生物を
シャール状に培養している写真です本当にこの写真だけでもわかると思うんですけども
いろんな色の微生物がいたりとか
いろんな大きさの微生物がいたりだとかいろんな形の微生物というのがこの世の中には
存在しています
そんな日政府の魅力を今日はお伝えできたと思います
生物と聞くと皆さんが一番パッドをイメージしやすいもの中に腸内細菌があるんじゃ
ないかと思っています
人のおなかの中には腸内細菌がたくさんいます重さでいうと1キロから1.5キロ程度
手数でいうと500種から選手程度の腸内細菌が存在しています
そしてヨーグルトなどの健康食品を食べることによって僕たちは腸内細菌の
コミュニティに変化を与えて自分たちの健康を守ってくれるまあこういうことが知られ
ています
もちろん超
腸内細菌以外にも自分の体の中にっていうのはとてもたくさんの微生物が存在してい
ます
口の中には口内細菌がいます皮膚の上には皮膚常在菌がいますそのように僕たちという
のは本当に微生物に囲まれて生きているんですね
そういうような質も体の中にいる微生物がいろんな
ea 今日だったり悪い影響を僕たちに及ぼしているということは
近年の研究でとてもは買ってきましたその一方で人の外側にいる微生物が僕たちにどの
ような影響を与えるか
それはまだ1歳分かっておりませんそのようなことに対して僕はとても疑問を持ちまし
たなぜ体の中にいる微生物はこんなにいろんな働きを知られているのにかかわらず外側
にいる微生物の影響というのはあまり知られていないんだろうということ
で僕は一つの実験場所を用意しましたそれがどこかというと日本の都市です
日本の都市東京大阪名古屋の三大都市には人口の半分程度の人が住んでいま
とても年には人が多くなっているというのは傾向は世界的にもそういう傾向知られてい
ます
果たしてその年皆さんが住んでいると死というのは本当に私たちの健康にとって最適な
場所と言えるのでしょうか
そこで安全に暮らしていけるのでしょうか
ところでみなさんこちらに来るにあたって電車やバスなどの公共交通機関を使ってきた
方が多分ほとんどだと思うんですけども
日本には複雑な公共交通機関が存在しています
毎朝電車はとても混みますしバスのでもとても混んでいると通勤通学ラッシュの時は
とても混んでいます
人がぎゅうぎゅうに押し詰められで満員でした運ばれていくということでそうなって
くると僕は社会問題が2つあると思っています
一つはないかというと公衆衛生が悪化することです
どのようなことかというと例えば梅雨の時期は夏などに満員電車に人がぎゅうぎゅうに
なって押し込めて運ばれていくと仲がとても汗臭かったりとか
もちろんいろんな匂いがするとそれはかなり公衆衛生の悪化例えば湿度がめちゃくちゃ
高くてちょっと仲間もはするなとか思ったりとかそういうことがあると思いますそして
二つ目は感染症の拡大ですこれどういうことかというと
冬などにインフルエンザや溶連菌などの微生物を由来とした病気がとても罹患する人が
増えますこれはやっぱり電車なども密室のような空間だとそういう微生物の交換が
行なわれてかなりそういう病原菌が広がってしまうということが懸念されています
なので私たちが住んでると死というのは意外にも危険なことがたくさんあるんじゃない
かそんなに僕たちは普通に暮らしてますけどその場所っていうのは健康じゃないんじゃ
ないかということを僕は持っています
そこで僕が打ち立てたのはゴーストプロジェクトですこちら
都市環境微生物の研究というの世界中で行われていて大きいコンソーシアムがありまし
て m- serve コンソーシアムというもので先導して研究が行われているん
ですけども
日本の都市環境微生物についてはあまり研究がされていませんでした
なので僕は号スタープロジェクトというものを東大上智渓太
学生たちと11人で立ち上げて今皆さんで研究を行っています
テーマとしましては日本における都市環境の大規模 dna 調査プロジェクトです
大規模な t エネ調査プロジェクトと申し上げたんですけどもやっていることは本当
にいたって簡単です
今皆さんが育ったリストか僕が立っているこのカーペットとかの dna を綿棒が
あるんですけども
写真の通り綿棒があってそこを3分間こするだけこれでそこの場所のいろんな
dna を取ってくることができるとそしたら微生物もそうだし
動植物も
そうだしありとあらゆる dna を持ったものを全てが僕のキャン指摘により分かる
ことができます
実際にサンプリングを行って一つの動画を見てください
muse fas
22 s 一緒に al 2
[音楽]
barbera アーレ aso デー
ana
ren
[音楽]
me
ます
b
ネオン hao chen ティガウスはラム
ということでまぁ今のようなサンプリングの方法で僕たちは微生物やその dna を
とっています
微生物研究の僕たちが行っている実行たちの簡単にご説明しますと
一番最初に先ほど行った綿棒で dena を収集するという方法があります
そして収集した dena から dna 以外のいらないものを取り除いてあげる
dena だけをとってきてあげると
dna 抽出という工程がありますそしてその抽出した dna というのを撤回こう
いう解析買い得機器がありましてそこに入れてあげると
コンピュータ上にデータとして dna が出てきますそしてそのデータ上になった
dna というのを僕は解析していますこの作業が僕はとても好きです
実際に dna というのは本当に4つの餅によって成り立って
んですけども4つのもしの組み合わせ次第で本当に様々な事実が dna から
読み取ることができます
一つこのような実行亭主の踏むとわかってくる結果を一つご説明します
2015年に海外のチームが発表した論文なんですけども
ニューヨークの地下鉄の dna を調べましたというものです
こちらニューヨークの地下鉄のも何百駅からもう dna を調べたんですけどもなん
と調べた dena のうち半分の dna というのが最近のてぃえねーでしたと
いうことでした
そしてなんと残りの約半分というのが未知の生物の dna が来たんですね僕たちが
暮らしていると知っていうのはまだまだ分からないことがたくさんあると
なのに僕たちは
をやって普段平然と暮らしていけるそれは何でなんだろうか本当に健康に被害はないん
だろうか僕はこの論文を見てとても疑問に思っています
そしてもう一つみなさんスマートフォンを買ってお持ちでしょうか
多分現在の方はほとんど持っていると思うんですけどもこのスマートフォンから個人の
ライフスタイルを予測するという stuck on you という企画がありまし
たこれは国際コンソーシアムまめちゃ様コンソーシアムがやっているんですけども
こちら
スマートもこれ僕のなんですけどもこのディスプレイから dna を取るんですね
そうすると皆さんがい夫妻の予測できるとこれどういうことかというとみなさんって
食事の最中とか食事終わったところに多分ほぼ必ず
すぐスマートフォンをいじりとが多いと思うんですね特に若い人はそうだと思うんです
けど
そうすると何が起きるかというと朝オレンジを食べましたとそしたらオレンジの dna
がスマートフォンに付着しますあ
さごはんを食べましたお米の dna がスマートフォンに付着します
それを僕たちは調べますそうするとあなた朝ごはん今日何食べたってことが割と的確に
予想できるんですね
日本であれば僕たちも同様の取り組みを日本でやってるんですけども
日本であれば例えば納豆とか味噌とかそういう微生物以来の食物が出るんじゃないか
っていうことで僕たちはおととしこれを実行しています
はいそうしまして僕たちがやりたいことの1つの目標としましては2020年の東京
オリンピックの存在があります
時オリンピックには訪日外国人が4000万人程度来ると言われているんですけども
その4000万に程度が自分の肌とか服とかにいろんな微生物を持って無意識のうちに
日本にも入ってくると
いうことなんですよ
なのでその微生物っていうのは日本に側持ち込まれてしまうとただそれがウイルスや
病原菌だった場合どうなっちゃうのってことなんですよ
日本の複雑な公共交通機関を使ってそれが広がってしまい
感染症の拡大や公衆衛生のアカー懸念されます
しかしながら我々はこの微生物の無意識的な流入というのを防ぐ術がありません
じゃあどうしようかということでじゃあそのインパクトとりあえず計測しようという
ことを僕たちは考えています
どうするかというとオリンピック前年度で
ある今年そして来年オリンピックと等開催年そして再来年というこの3ポイントで
dena を取ってあげると当初の的なにとってあげます
そうすることによってオリンピックの開催前後出ると病原菌やウイルスなどが
都市の中で増えたか減ったかそういうものを調べられると僕たちは思っていていま
今年から研究をスタートしています
究極の目標としましては僕たち号サーブ抱えるゲートる目標としましては
都市における人と微生物の共生関係を明らかにしたいそしてその共生関係を明らかに
自体上での次世代の都市デザインを行いたいということです
例えば今皆さんが座っている椅子その椅子の材質は果たして本当に最適でしょう
か悪い微生物が繁殖しやすくはないでしょうか皆さんが住んでいる家の間取りというの
は本当に微生物の多様性に考慮されているでしょうか
県大では殺菌や抗菌などの微生物を排除する働きというのがとても良いとされているん
ですけど僕はその逆だと思って言って都市環境内で微生物の多様性というのを僕たちが
住みやすいように健康に出られるように適切に処理してあげる
適切な対応栓してあげるそういうことができる
言えば微生物を排除せずとも僕たちはきっと健康な社会を築けるはずです以上は号
サーブのしたいことでした以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]